[Musik]
guten morgen mache keinen sinn weil das
video wahrscheinlich am abend sehen
werdet allerdings nicht wirklich recht
herzlich zu einem neuen youtube-video in
beiden kanal provinzen und ich lege mein
bett ich glaube ich an ihm video hier
nicht in meinem bett aufgenommen endlich
hat man dafür ist hauptberuflicher
youtube aus den aufnahmen zu machen
ich trinke jeden morgen sollen zitrone
minh city noch mit seinem schuss
magnesium bisschen vitamin c vitamin d
tropfen rein und dann dann wird so
herzlich wie ich ich hoffe euch jetzt
gut meine lieben freunde ich das fühlt
sich total falsche hand normalerweise
schlafe ich halte hier und hab halt
jeden tag mehrfach ich bin natürlich
auch gedacht und wat mir hey ich hatte
irgendwie gerade bock drauf bisschen
quatschen die stadt übrigens auch immer
mit einer schlafmaske als einmal mit
schlafmaske und normalerweise stellt
euch mal vor ich hätte jetzt von der
kerb ja wir haben tatsächlich einige
sachen zu bereden meine lieben freunde
denn ich habe mich verändert
den kommentar ich in letzter zeit gar
nicht mal so häufig gelesen aber locker
zwei dreimal und man achtet halt immer
nur solche bösen kommentare irgendwie
das ist in der natur des menschen
verankert von daher das peace and
harmony corona ticker alter ich dachte
die dielen noch drogen alte nicht nur
tausende impftermine in sachsen frei
lauterbach fordert strikten lockt mit
deutschland biologe rechnen irgendwie
schocken diese kur oder nachrichten
nicht mehr oder nicht lässt
kalt wenn ich ein unmensch dadurch weiß
es nicht aber irgendwie immer nimmt das
einfach nur noch so
man lebt halt mittlerweile irgendwie
damit womit man aber nicht mehr reden
sollte ist das geht zu viel butter auf
so belegten brötchen beim bäcker ist
abonniert meinen kanal wenn ihr jetzt
genauso sieht das statische petition man
mache ich auch eine petition gegen
sendungsverfolgung nummern
das sind mittendrin ich erwarte seit
wochen ein paket von fedex wie nennt man
es wenn die in ein ex-partner
übergewichtig war
[Musik]
eigentlich müssten wir die zähne putzen
früher habe ich mir die zähne direkt
nach dem aufstehen putze mittlerweile
erst nachdem ich was gegessen oder
getrunken habe was er für ein mensch hat
und in die kommentare
jetzt aber endlich mal auf dem video
titel hier einzugehen bei der liebe
freunde ich habe mich verändert
ninety nine präsident angel
kennt ihr diese instagram passions oder
bios menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend steht die scheiße ist auch
immer wenn ich mir die zähne produkt
einfach mal die nase oder haben muss ich
mir immer noch kanal wirst du die nase
putzen weil es so juckt und dann bin ich
sitze mit dieser die nase putzen aber
gut wie ihr hier ist endlich auf das
video thema einmal eine liebe freunde
viele leute drei ich habe einige
kommentare in den letzten tagen gelesen
die in die richtung gehen ein lokal was
sich viel verändert und immer wenn ich
das halt sehe denke ich brauche ja klar
denkt ihr ich bin der gleiche ich die
ich vor acht jahren war als mit youtube
angefangen habe ich glaub nicht und es
wäre auch ziemlich scheiße wenn ich der
gleiche mensch mehrere welt vorab ja
noch gewesen war wurde sein pate die
kommentare kramen glaube ich primär weil
ich meinen namen auf youtube wieder
geändert habe und luca zu laser luca
[Musik]
das ist aber kein problem beide lieben
freunde denn ich trage das neue luxus
shirt was am sonntag um 15 uhr lauten
die tipps der wiener von de zum glück
hab ich keine weiße weste schafft sich
ab sonntag übrigens auch geburtsdaten 25
heißt ich bin eher an der 30 als an der
20iger was geht ab alles was nicht
richtig befestigt ist
es kam auf jeden fall einige du hast
dich verändert kommentare einfach nur
weil ich meinen youtube namen geändert
habe und da wollte ich ganz kurz darauf
eingehen weil auch einige - dazu kamen
[Musik]
der ließ sich akon crafter den namen
habe ich einfach genommen wegen
minecraft da ich zu dem zeitpunkt
eigentlich nur minecraft videos
hochgeladen habe hättet ihr endlich mal
wieder bock auf minecraft hat eigentlich
schon bock irgendwie auch so ein stream
projekt da ich dann allerdings neben
mannschaft auch noch andere sachen
hochgeladen habe habe ich mich auf
kontrakt das liegt schlicht luca
umbenannt weil halt auch so ein bisschen
wie ihr leid krams mit drin war und in
riyadh bin ich halt nicht komplett
sondern man kann gar kein minecraft mehr
deswegen da ich dann nur noch luca auf
laser komme ich mich einfach unbedingt
weil ich heiß auf install acer auf tik
tok auf slapshot überall und das
mehrfach allem eines social media
networks sind so allerdings hat meiner
ansicht nach mein name überhaupt nix
damit dorf liegt weg auch gut doch die
flut schon wieder eine vorgegebene
strecke ist vorgestern vogel gegen die
scheibe geflogen und ist etwas anderes
scheibe kleben geblieben ist seine
chance ich glaube ich hoffe der rest war
schlecht das mal vor ich habe sonst
guter bringen wo so ein mädel ab und
dann bräuchten der unfall und einige
haben dieses du hast dich verändert dann
halt auf meinen namen bezogen und meinte
hey du hast jetzt nicht mehr lukas und
lesern kam war aus bis ein ganz anderer
mensch geworden dass ich in einfamilien
ich sehe andere meinen allerdings dass
ich mein content verändert hat in den
letzten monaten oder jahren wo ich auch
ganz klar sagen muss ja natürlich
also ich entwickle mich die ganze zeit
weiter und für mich war es immer so dass
youtube mir spaß machen sollte und
gerade macht einfach spaß mich nicht
jeden tag zu zwingen was hochzuladen
sondern manchmal auch ein tag
auszusetzen und dann mal im sonntag
nehmen um einfach mal zu entspannen weil
der gesundheit zu hören
runde spazieren zu gehen ich war
letztens baden das war aber ziemlich
scheiße aber für mich war es einfach in
ein land schnell gesprochen wichtig dass
ich mich von nichts unter druck setzen
lassen dass ich weiter in mein ding
machen und jetzt
nicht irgendwie übernehmen mit
irgendwelchen trends oder hypes gehen
muss von wegen jeder macht jetzt pokémon
partner unbedingt das heißt müssten auch
in die 10.000 euro investieren ich mag
das worauf ich bock habt und wenn ich da
wach geworden bin und mir denke hey ich
hab keinen bock zu reden auch wenn es
vielleicht nicht so viele leute feiern
ich finde ich das könnte ich noch
erzählen könnte das wenn ihr
beispielsweise schreibt eure mutter habt
und dann stellt sie euch danach
irgendwie eine frage und ihr würdet
eigentlich richtig kennen ja sagen so
von wegen hey weil ich zu bekommen da
hin oder möchte auch als es dann gesagt
nein einfach weil die streit hat und ihr
wollt so noch zeigen hey ich bin ja nein
wenn man rede ich irgendwie mit der
kamera und denkt dann kommt dann was
raus ist ja antwortet aber es halt nicht
der fall und ich habe auch keine freunde
den ich das dann erzählen kann deswegen
das dann meistens oder sich die kamera
auch wenn ich aufwache ich mache ja auch
immer alleine auch weil ich keine freude
wurde er direkt jetzt ja kann ich alles
rund alles die wäsche das war hauptsitz
ist alles ist jetzt das
nie nie wieder mache ich das hier gut
weil der liebe freunde ich hoffe euch
das video hier gefallen das ist jetzt
echt ekelhaft ihr gerade ich hoffe euch
hat dieser alltag mit luca gefallen war
aus der serie machen ich habe schon
genug serien auf dem kanal über was soll
ich das nächste mal reden meine lieben
freunde schreibt wir gerne und in die
kommentare findet ihr ich habe mich
verändert schreibt sie gerne die
kommentare postet eure zähne form oder
nach dem frühstück und schreibt sogar
die kommentare und seht ihr mich auf
einer vespa so durch italien fahren
alterswehr chance sich mit einem mädel
oder oder alleine oder so
[Musik]